so nice to see you i have to tell you
you are a breath of fresh air on this
season
i enjoyed how you came in and wanted to
give everybody a fresh shot your energy
was fantastic what did it feel like for
you just coming into a series like this
oh
my god it was
it's funny because it was a dream come
true in a way that i always wanted to
reach out to people i mean not as an
actress but also as someone that could
like you know show how i am and helping
out in other ways as an actress i'm
always i'm normally the villain
it's not a lot that i will help through
that so i think
i think it was a dream come true to just
come and join you know my acting in a
way like you know an experience on tv
with real estate which is another dream
now through you know what happened to my
sister so
uh yeah it just feels amazing and i feel
super thankful and and honored to to be
doing this right now
yeah i mean also with selling sunset
um what does it feel like to be on a
series that is so heavily recognized
there are so many eyes on it what did it
feel like for you just jumping right in
uh well i mean
obviously i think it was i i said this
before really joining the
obviously the show and the office was a
little bit like when you go to school
for the first day but like sure
sometimes better and worse
more nervous
uh yeah because again obviously you know
it comes with a it's a it's a blessing
but it comes with a lot of
responsibility too because it's you know
it's a successful
show so i didn't even
i sometimes i'm like i'm pinch me am i
living this is this real
um but it feels incredible to be a part
of this i've worked my whole life
i think that sometimes god works in
mysterious ways and
you know you never know how your things
and how your dreams are going to come
true but they'll they always do if you
keep believing in them and you hold the
bar
into those positive
thoughts
well it seemed like it was really
important for you when you joined this
group to come in
and sort of give everybody a fair shot
was that something that you just you
were you held on because that was
challenged for you over and over again
but you you stuck to your guns with that
was that really important to you
yes 100 i always like to to keep true to
myself and um
i'm not someone that will
uh take a side or anything you know with
someone that they have not nothing to me
why would i not think you know
if they show me that they're sweet and
loving and sweet and funny that's that's
what i'm taking from them and then in in
any case you know with christine
um i can see that she's coming from a
place of pain
i do recognize that there might be
people that don't agree with me but i do
know because i
a person that have
been hurt in my life a lot
from so many things so i know when
you're coming from a place of pain that
you know you can probably not
not recognize when you're doing uh
something that you can be better at and
i that's why i was like well i'll tell
you with my mindset coach and then let's
see you know that helps you because i
feel that she's right now like i was and
it's it's not maybe the perfect
comparison but when i lost my sister i
think i was in an
in a in a spiral of negative and sadness
and you know and i feel
her she was like in this
energy with the girls of having problems
with them over and over and over and
and i think that maybe if she changes
the way that she that she thinks maybe
it would be easier for her to
have
maybe not react or maybe not
continue having the problems that she
has had with with the girls my intention
all the time was to just help everyone
there and just you know have a peaceful
and beautiful environment and as a
friend i'll be there for her
yeah i know you could really really see
that how is your friendship now with
christine i mean because yeah you you
did you stuck your neck out for her you
know with in more ways than one with the
other women but also looking for
tangible change to help her as as a
woman and as a person grow
yes i mean i'm still i'm i still you
know message her and she's you know she
was traveling a lot and now we're both
busy with press uh but i love her and i
you know i i really appreciate the
person that she's been with me
um since day one you know obviously she
was one of probably the one i was the
most nervous when i met her i thought
you know maybe like she she actually
said it like i i wanted to be with you
but i can't
so
i was learning my language but that's
what she said
yeah so uh yeah i mean she's been super
sweet and very good friend and i'm
always going to be here for her no
matter what i i'm a friend that i'm i
never give up on my friends
and as long as they're my friends or
they're good with me i'm always be there
i'm gonna i'm gonna be there so as a
result now that the season's over how is
your relationship with the other ladies
on the show oh it's lovely i mean i'm
very blessed because i've never thought
that i would be working with so many
successful and beautiful women and i
will have a good relationship with all
of them because in my in my career is
not very likely to to have so many women
that
are not you know not going to be like
in a negative competitive uh
attitude and thank god it's been you
know very lovely and sweet i mean if we
have an event i mean you know they
invite me and then i go and then we
support each other
and you know it's uh it's just been a
it's been a great adventure to get to
know all of them i mean i'm still i
still have a lot to
to learn from them and not only as
persons but also as real estate agents
they inspire me
yeah well that's the thing that you know
people may forget in in all of this you
have you're all reality stars for sure
but this is a business like at the end
of the day
uh homes are being sold so here's my
question
which celebrity would you like
to represent like whose house would you
like to get into you can sell anyone
oh lady gaga
i love her
i mean that's the first one that comes
in my head uh i actually just saw that
pink which is another thing
that i love
she just listed her house in malibu i
was like oh no
i wish i was
listing her property uh
um so yeah maybe i mean right now those
two come to my head uh
but yeah i mean it would be a dream to
lady gaga i know that she has a house in
malibu
uh and i'm a big big big fan she's
incredible as a person and as a singer
so
that would be amazing so lady gaga if
you're listening to this interview
you're watching him for some reason
please
call me and let me leave your house
listen i have to tell you lady gaga fans
watch et canada and they're very
powerful so gaga fans let's go i think
let's
yeah
this dream come true
we're going to make things happen we're
going to put this on social it's going
to go everywhere
i love it
lastly how would your personal life
change since being thrust into such a an
incredible family and really into the
the spotlight the way you have been in
this season
well it's funny because i don't i i
don't think i have seen it as much as i
think i mean i think i'm starting to see
it but most of the days i've been on
sums or doing work from home
i need to find a pokemon computer
yeah but the other day i went uh i mean
it's it's kind of similar like when i
was on tv doing soap operas like a lot
of people are like oh how can i take a
photo but now it's
the thing that changes and it makes me
more
more powerful is that it's they're
talking about me
yeah like it's not your favorite
right exactly so uh the other day yeah i
went out with my boyfriend and we went
uh for coffee and then we went to the
supermarket and then if while we were
walking on the street i i was stopped
like every two or three minutes oh my
god i saw you and then these and that
but you your personality thank you for
these and that and then we went to uh
the grove in in l.a and in the same it
was i think it was the
the same day or that this weekend i
really like took try to go out and and
kind of like feel
the love for vanessa and obviously a
show but not for a character but yeah no
it's amazing and what does your
boyfriend think he must just love it
yeah yeah
he's the most sweet because he actually
helps me to take photos like with the
fans or you know they're like yeah you
can take a photo and then doing this and
he's yeah he's very supportive so i'm
happy
well listen we love your energy on the
show you're such a light and um
we're really excited that you're there
it's just you make this season
really nice you vanessa oh thank you so
lovely to speak to you too and uh i hope
i can go to your studio soon i will come
to canada
yes